all right let's go back to the phones at
six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty going to our caller from the
three three one area code caller from
three three one what's your name where
you calling from my name is Curtis
calling from Aurora hey Curtis what's up
I'm what first happy New Year to you and
the guys over there doing good stuff man
Patriot mail thanks a lot babe
appreciate that my specific question was
so in light of the psychiatric nurse
left the voicemail for Tia and then some
of the other great guests that you had
on in regards to Trump the narcissism
neurologically accusing possible
psychological issues
my question is you had a tweet that
asked I'm not mistaken what his worst
moment was in 2019
I thought Dingle the dingo comments were
the lowest and most deplorable comments
ever I was wondering what you thought
his worst was I couldn't I mean there's
just there's so many it's a I'm actually
the wrong person even yes a what Donald
Trump's worst moment was in 2019 because
I've become so desensitized to the fact
that we have this outrageous person in
the Oval Office so I actually am NOT
well positioned to tell you what the
worst moment was all right understood
understood yeah it's well I think he's
had a lot I think he'll continue to have
more just based on the individual years
but those specific people who speak to
that that's a bad loss they always make
for a great and very enlightening show
so that's a good thing so I appreciate
that yeah listen I mean I thought I
might awk about the Trump cognitive
decline or mental health stuff there's
always a portion of the audience that
says you know it's irresponsible to be
talking about a person who you've not
personally met or who hasn't been
examined it's like this is the problem
that if we can't actually figure out
what's going on because you won't be
examined and the behavior is so erratic
and examination would be appropriate so
what else can we do we're left in a very
tough position very true very true well
this we have a good rest of this year
sir and thanks for your doing alright my
friend thank you very much great to hear
from you